the fourth and final part of netflix's
sabrina is a veritable pandora's box of
eldritch terrors and og aunties with an
intensely emotional ending that will
have many fans wishing for another
season
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm breaking down the series
finale of chaos
clues and theories about what would have
happened in the now cancelled part 5 and
whether sabrina could still return
obviously spoilers ahead so take care
the main events of the finale kick off
when sabrina morningstar crashes through
the magic mirror as she returns from the
duplicate cosmos having fled the
alternate earth with a talking salem
who's actually an eldritch terror
himself she arrives back in sabrina
spelman's bedroom and warns her that the
void is on its way to destroy the earth
but morningstar's escape and journey
between the two worlds has left her
badly injured and she and salem
quickly die in an effort to stop the
void sabrina spellman is about to make a
wish on the reality altering imp of the
perverse when the mysterious trinket
salesman shows up
sabrina trades the imp for pandora's box
the mythical object
said to have unleashed evil and terror
into the world sabrina using pandora's
fabled box against the eldritch terrors
which blackwood summoned is a nice
callback to part
two when she taunted him about her
newfound powers to resurrect and perform
miracles
the gods give pandora a jar containing
all the sorrows of the world
they armed her for vengeance father
blackwood for destruction
do you really want to open that lid
sabrina then ventures into the void
alone and actually wants to take full
responsibility for the impending
apocalypse she blocks off the magic
mirror so no one can follow her
given that the void by definition
represents nothingness the design the
chaos
team came up with is interesting the
pictures in the room are by the renowned
dutch graphic artist
m.c escher who is known for his
depictions of mathematical and
impossible objects
for example when you look at this pair
of hands drawing the image creates a
strange illusionary loop in your mind so
you can't tell where the picture begins
or ends
and it seems like a fitting choice
perhaps given it was sabrina's refusal
to go back and complete the time loop at
the end of part 3 which
led to this situation in the first place
when you're done with everything you
have to come back
to right here right now and do what i
just did
to complete the time loop it's the only
way to keep the realms preserved
another intriguing piece of ash's art in
the void is day and night with its
symmetrical mirroring of dark and light
birds flying in opposite directions that
merge into a patchwork of tiled fields
below
this piece seems to perfectly represent
sabrina's dual nature with her mortal
and infernal sides as well as the
merging of the two different but same
sabrina's this season
now that she's in the void sabrina opens
up pandora's box which starts sucking
the final eldritch terror into it but
this time it's not her
impetuousness that messes up the plan as
it's often done in the past
instead back on earth her aunties
ambrose and nick have cast a spell that
brings spelman's soul back into morning
star's dead body
and although the void appears to have
been defeated when they discover it's
disappeared from the academy's
observatory
weird things begin to happen the next
day it's sabrina's 17th birthday one
year on from the events of the first
season and objects and even people start
to mysteriously disappear around her
the scan reveals that sabrina's insides
appear empty and they realize the voids
now inside her
understanding she's a threat to everyone
and everything around her
sabrina selflessly banishes herself to
the mountains of madness to protect
those she loves
blackwood who knows the voids arrived
seeks out sabrina with the intention of
sacrificing her by
draining out the eldritch terror then
containing it and consuming it to obtain
its powers
similar to when he ate a piece of the
uninvited team spellman goes to the
mountains of madness for a final
showdown with blackwood in the void
during which faustus is neutralized
after they trick him with a fake
pandora's box blinding him with
gunpowder
however sabrina who's been learning
everything about the void explains that
blackwood's plan to bloodletter is still
the only way to extract the eldritch
terror from inside her
and although she and her aunties fear
the worst she shows strength leadership
and bravery in her final moments
the void believes in nothing thinks we
don't matter but we do
we have strength and a bond that the
void can't
touch so let's finish this the way we
always do together it's a very emotional
moment given the risks and even a little
iron man end game-esque
and just before they begin there's a
little bit of foreshadowing of how nick
will end up joining sabrina in the
afterlife i'll see you on the other side
as the white void flows out of sabrina
she tries to hold on but it just takes
too long
and in her final moment she says goodbye
to everyone as a montage flashes past
it's a heartbreaking time for nick
especially when he emerges last from the
void to tell sabrina they saved everyone
only to learn she's dead nick and
sabrina of course do end up together in
the very final scene of the series as he
joins her in the suite hereafter
revealing he went swimming in the sea of
sorrows and drowned
whether he meant that literally or
figuratively it seems he was determined
to be with sabrina and decided to join
it in the afterlife
sabrina spellman we're endgame that's
similar to what sabrina told harvey in
part three about him and roz who also
end up together by the end of the series
you guys are in game a couple of
interesting details are that sabrina now
has a white headband rather than the
black or red ones we've seen her with
and as nick and sabrina kiss he pulls
her hand to the chain around his neck
that holds his locket
the other one of which he gave her for
her 17th birthday
one for me and one for you so that i'll
always be able to find you
a few other moments foreshadowing this
scene include when nick told sabrina
that he wanted to be part of her world
calm down ariel and also as sabrina is
dying you can hear a little echo of her
telling nick
i'm never letting you go that's
something sabrina said to nick in part
three
after he returned to her from being
trapped with lucifer in the acheron
i'm never letting you go and although i
have mixed feelings about this final
scene and how the series ended
it's worth noting that sabrina looks
happy and at peace with herself even
before nick arrives
that's because sabrina learning to love
herself was a big theme in part four we
will always be loved
we are each other we have each other and
we love each other
then there was that great moment when
the two sabrinas just hung out and had
fun dancing with each other
we also see how sabrina comes to
understand that although she can have a
boyfriend if she chooses she doesn't
absolutely need one to be happy
who needs boys when we have each other
amusingly though spellman does have a
gut making her own
ideal man using the candle she inscribed
with nick and harvey's name in part
three
may be the best of both nick and harvey
and although things don't exactly work
out with lucas hunt
sabrina quickly moves on from the
briefling and flushes the waxman down
the drain
boys i think i need to be alone for a
little while
i need to figure out who i am it's great
to see sabrina maturing in this way in
her final season as it's been something
of an intentional running joke through
the series about how she often plows
ahead doing exactly the opposite of what
everyone else is recommending
this criticism's been a little unfair at
times given she's only young and will
naturally want to do her own thing
and be curious rebellious and even
foolhardy at times
and despite a few stumbles such as
getting drunk and causing a scene at
hilda's wedding
by the time the eldritch terror the
cosmic appears on the horizon
sabrina and her doppelganger decide to
step up to the plate and take full
accountability
this mess is our fault we won't be
responsible for countless deaths of
witches mortals and infernals
the idea that sabrina's reckless
decisions would culminate in a grand
reckoning
was mentioned way back in part two by
her aunt hilda
everything has a price that's how
witchcraft works but i don't think
there's a price for me oh
not anymore you are racking up a cosmic
debt the like of which the world has
never seen
owning up to the problem both sabrina's
agree to a risky merge procedure that
will cause at least one of them to lose
their memories and identity
a neat callback to when sabrina
intercepted herself at the end of part
three
shouldn't we merge or something ambrose
would say so
yes but i have a supes crazy idea i like
the way this scene is framed with the
twins lying next to each other on a
stone slab with sabrina morningstar on
the left and spellman on the right
referencing the dream that sabrina had
in the very first episode of season one
when she came across a pair of baby
twins on a large stone in the woods
and the baby on the left had hooved feet
like the devil
and although that merge is abandoned in
a sense
both sabrina's do end up merged in the
end when spellman's soul is transferred
into morning star's body
because the series was cancelled after
filming for part four had been completed
there are some big plot points and
character arcs that were left wide open
to explore in what would have been the
next season
lilith had an especially traumatic time
in part 4 with caliban first cursing her
pregnant belly to explode which almost
killed her and then
lucifer threatening to take away her son
as romulus and remus suckled on the teat
of a wolf
so our sons shall suckle on the teat of
a hellhound
you have six last hours to spend with
adam in a desperate act rather than hand
her baby over to the dark lord
she kills him and serves him as a meal
which also serves as revenge for when
lucifer killed mary wardwell's fiance
adam in the second season and cooked him
as dinner for lilith
enraged lucifer strips lilith of her
powers and inflicts her with human
weakness but the inability to die
so she asked caliban to get her the
spear of longinus so she can kill
herself
but after zelda convinces her not to
throw her life away
she uses it to stab lucifer after he
reneges on a deal to restore her
abilities
it's a gruesome but powerful moment when
she consumes his celestial blood and
powers
with lucifer cast out of hell and
caliban stuck in the void
the season ends with madame satan back
in charge of the infernal realm
and it would have been fascinating to
see what she would have got up to in
part
5. the series long-running villain
father blackwood is finally defeated by
the very end as prudence chops him up
into tiny pieces to scatter across the
world
even with his immortality it would be
highly unlikely he'd ever reform his
body again however continuing his work
is ms
wardwell who we see reading the eldritch
gospel to the pilgrims of the night
church
and recounting the events of the final
episode so her fifth season could have
brought her back as a potential
antagonist
there were also numerous pointers to a
war brewing throughout part four
with a few scenes showing that the
denizens of hell were unhappy with the
greendale coven's worship of the goddess
hecate
but the witches are without the dark
lord's gifts
they now worship equity they
mean whoa and we know from show renault
roberto aguirre
that part five was originally going to
deal with what he called a witch war
i also expect that originally sabrina's
death in part 4 wasn't going to be
permanent
and would have been reversed in some way
in fact there's a line that zelda says
to hilda after burying both the sabrinas
that seems to hint at this
why did you not preserve her dark mother
it's not right
it's just not right that she's gone
zelda is referring to hecate and how
they all prayed to her during sabrina's
bloodletting to keep her alive
we've already seen how hecate has been
able to bring the dead back to life in
the series for instance hilda in part 3
which makes me wonder whether there was
originally an alternate ending that at
least hinted at sabrina's return
perhaps the original final scene was
just a flicker of life from sabrina's
grave
ala batman vs superman or whether that
would have just been seen at the start
of part 5.
of course in a supernatural world like
chaos anything can happen and even the
showrunner has hinted that there could
be something still to come after part 4.
although whether this is just the
promised comic book follow-up or a
spin-off prequel or crossover in
riverdale remains to be seen
and if you haven't had enough sabrina
yet you can discover more of the amazing
details and easter eggs cleverly hidden
in the show in my chaos things you
missed video
tap here to watch that or follow the
link in the video description
so what were your thoughts on the fourth
and final season of chilling adventures
were you happy with the ending or what
else would you like to have seen
leave your comments below and if you
enjoyed this don't forget to leave a
thumbs up it's hugely appreciated
next tap left for my next sabrina video
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers